[Music]
walk inside moderna's technology center
and you'll feel like you stepped into
one of the leading companies of silicon
valley
avant-garde scaling up rapidly
buzzing with energy
[Music]
but this production hub is located just
outside of boston
a former polaroid manufacturing plant
which moderna refers to as a campus with
neighborhoods nice to meet you nice to
meet you as well scott nickerson
oversees the facility where moderna's
first coveted 19 vaccine was created in
january 2020. and that all started right
here all started right here madeira's
next challenge is staying ahead of the
virus by tailoring booster shots to
emerging variants how long does it take
to create a booster so let me just give
you a feel for how we did it to get to
phase one gmp material here we were able
to take from sequence and get it into a
vial and test it and release it in 42
days and so could it be as quick if
you're talking about a booster targeting
a specific area it can be just as quick
moderna is able to pivot so quickly
because of the game-changing mrna
technology
every one of its products begins when a
dna sequence is entered into its
proprietary software and transcribed
into messenger rna or mrna which gives
the body instructions on how to fight a
foreign invader
the mrna is then purified covered in a
fatty envelope called the lipid
nanoparticle filtered frozen and shipped
to be bottled so at this scale we can
manufacture of action about five days
quality control is high tech as well
this is actually technology that's used
by the nfl to track performance of
athletes a receiver mounted on the
ceiling tracks every operator through a
sensor in their id badge so employees
who are assigned to work in one drug
product area each meticulously color
coded and taped off don't cross over
into another if you're assigned to the
yellow train as you call it correct and
you step across the blue tape what
happens we will be able to have an alarm
that tells us that they went a place
they shouldn't go wow yeah it's
important
keeping pace with the virus means
knowing where to pivot and at madarana's
headquarters half an hour away they've
tested more than a hundred different
variants to see if they need to create a
new vaccine
modernist president stephen hogue
do you have teams of people back there
trying to forecast where the next
variant may occur oh absolutely and not
only that um the moment that we see a
new variant emerge the moment there's
the first posting of a new sequence to
the international databases we download
that we look at all of the different
mutations that are merged and we ask
ourselves the question is this the
canary in the coal mine is this the one
that we're worried about moderna
currently has six different boosters in
development including one combined with
a flu shot another targeting the delta
variant delta
surprised us delta as a variant is far
more transmissible but fortunately delta
is not an immune escape variant and what
i mean by that it's not one that has
really hidden itself from our vaccines
or our immune systems the big concern
that we have scientifically right now
are are some of those things that
increased ability to infect and the
ability to hide from the immune system
are they going to co-evolve in a new
variant the approach we're taking
scientifically is we're bringing forward
what's called a multivalent vaccine but
multiple different variants of concern
and trying to protect against the places
we think the virus is going to go
while moderna's original vaccine is
effective against the main variants in
circulation the question is will it
become less effective over time
and will we need a booster to increase
immunity well as a company moderna we
think yes our clinical trials which are
the longest exposures to the vaccine and
the virus that we have are starting to
suggest to us that it's it's time to get
get concerned and get ready hogg says
moderna will ask health canada to
approve a booster six months after your
second shot
the booster would be a half dose using
the original vaccine formulation this is
from one of our clinical trials and what
you can see is after the first two doses
of vaccine you see this very significant
increase in the level of neutralizing
protection in your blood that's good but
as you follow it out towards six months
there's this general trend down and at
some point that decline will be to such
a low level that it might not be
providing you any protection in your
blood we should expect antibodies to
weigh now you would expect antibodies to
wane and it just because they fall all
the way down one day doesn't mean that
you'd have breakthrough cases of covert
19 on the vaccine but breakthrough cases
among its clinical trial participants
started to emerge
people who were fully vaccinated and
still got covered 19. as we got into the
summer and saw delta we actually started
to see the significant increase almost
hockey stick like increase in the number
of cases and that really is the
intersection of this declining immunity
and an increasing force of infection
from delta at about one year in the
united states that causes us to say we
think a booster dose of the vaccine
we'll get that neutralizing immunity
back up where it was and nice and strong
and stop those breakthrough cases
the other mrna vaccine manufacturer
pfizer biontec is also advocating for a
booster
saying the effectiveness of its two-dose
vaccine dips from 96 percent to 84
percent four to six months out so what
do we mean by a dip in vaccine
protection and the devil is very much in
the details
dr denudis koronsky leads a team at the
british columbia center for disease
control which is tracking vaccine
effectiveness in real time
her methodology first used in influenza
in 2004 has been adopted around the
world
and the findings will help guide the
province on whether to administer a
booster it's not a done deal in my mind
there are still
gaps in knowledge that we need to fill
in order to make a determination
dr swaronski says the protection from
two doses of an mrna vaccine is
outstanding
it's important to remember that
the goal of the covid 19 vaccination
program is to minimize hospitalizations
and deaths severe outcomes
so if we can achieve that we've achieved
the goal of the program
on preventing severe outcomes data shows
both mrna vaccines are still performing
well the concern is that if those
breakthrough infections eventually
become severe infections and then god
forbid death we really will wish that we
had boosted people to maintain the high
level protection they've been enjoying
through the early part of this year
the drive to understand how covet 19
vaccines are working is spurring
research around the world
including at the university of montreal
hospital research center where
virologist andres finzee arrives before
dawn so the antibodies are important but
they don't explain the full situation
finzi and his partner dr daniel kaufman
are studying the immune response to the
vaccine
and caution
gauging its durability based solely on
antibodies is missing half the story the
message could be a bit dangerous if we
say if the antibodies decrease
it's an indication or if you get
infected but not sick at all you eat the
negation for booster
that's because the other key piece to
immune protection is at the cellular
level up to six months plus vaccination
studies
from from the u.s and other places and
we are getting
similar results we are measuring that
the cellular responses are there
it's when these these cells are kind of
quiet you know kind of dormant but when
they see
a pathogen against it's not the
antibodies that wake up it's these cells
that wake up and then begin to produce
antibodies again
what dr swaronski points out is that
while some countries may be moving ahead
with boosters the canadian experience
where many provinces delayed second
doses by up to four months
may be different
when you have a longer interval between
the first and the second dose you
generally get higher
vaccine
immune responses i think in retrospect
we will probably say that time between
the doses extended the durability of the
vaccine so is it plausible because
canadians took longer to get the second
dose they won't need a booster as
quickly as others i think it's not only
plausible i think it's likely because
the more recently you were boosted with
your second dose the less likely you're
going to need a third dose booster the
challenge of that for all of us is you
you also don't want to wait too long and
if you received your second dose the in
the summer um
six months from now it could become a
very bad moment because you'll see high
forces of infection and breakthroughs
come christmas time in canada things
could look very different
i think that's the concern that in
christmas things could look very
different
ultimately it will fall to health canada
to make a decision on boosters weighing
the safety the ethics
and the necessity